the steam wand
hey everyone and welcome to our guide to
need for speed payback brought to you by
EA I'm Dan joined by Anna Mises own
yearning very well thank you
now this time we're gonna be looking at
the different types of car class the
driving styles that you can access in
payback so you've got racers you've got
off-road you've got Griff you've got
runner and you've got drag which are
those five - thinker describes you best
six lunatic lunatic I like that should
be a bonus style so let's go into those
let's explain the differences and see
how that changes your race experience in
payback so let's start off the first
character introduced in the game is
Tyler and he is the race of style driver
this is the guy who's the sort of
all-rounder who drives speedy cars
drives them well you've had a bit of
hands-on with with racer with Tyler what
do you make of it
it's enjoyable it's fun I like the
challenges obviously look we've got the
oncoming you're 18 seconds left you can
send the oncoming lane for another 18
second 16 now we'll win that as well yes
a racer challenges tend to be geared
around skillful driving in this case
they want us to win the race but also
stay in the oncoming traffic lane and as
people have played these games before no
doing things like driving the oncoming
lane are the the best way to get that
nitrous boost as well but don't take you
off the ball note otherwise things like
this happen so Mac he's the master
off-road and drifting and our guide a
goal right now is to perform some school
trips which I believe you're a fan of
going someplace near loves sideways love
going around and around it's just all
sideways so the car is geared up to go
sideways yeah it's not about top-end
speed so this is probably the most
unorthodox of the five racing styles in
there in there Jesse's a runner but she
which pacing means that she's a really
good getaway driver
actually a nice Aldi so I think this is
one of the stars the runner is it's more
likely to sort of point in the
directions of going through shortcuts
parking lots things like that
anything goes pretty much basically yet
so what we're looking at now our drag
races this is Tyler's other speciality
and what's interesting about drag races
is that they are completely unlike
anything else not just in payback but I
think in any racing game I've ever seen
and I've never done sort of drag racing
in a game before the tactics are very
very different this is obviously about
raw horsepower and it's about judicious
application of nitrous as well but if
she see here it's also about management
of this bar at the top and manual
shifting which think you don't have to
worry about with the other ones but
because you're not focused on steering
you can focus on that so got a perfect
start by keeping the green and then well
all the late shift because I did so well
on that first one that can do it so
everything that bar hits that green
you've got to hit the Y button and get
that nitrous boost nice so now this is
the other set of races the the other
Street League this is the one that the
Mac take spine because these are all the
off-road focus races so we are in a nice
suit of defender six-man race is that
there's definitely a different feel to
these off-road race as well because
there's so much more sort of freedom to
the way I mean obviously check the check
points are there to keep you on track
but there's still an element of freedom
in terms of which direction you tackle
them right here we go finish line and
boom nice so that's your introduction to
paybacks five driving stars with a
little bit of Yanni's preferred six
method lunatic just thrown into all four
for good measure there's something there
for everybody really but if you want to
get the most out of payback
it's really gonna pay to master all five
of them join us next time where we're
going to be doing a spot of detective
work intriguing
see you next time